I don't know what happened you're
supposed to take her to the fireflies
and walk away
they were actually gonna make a cure
the only catch never killer
the Last of Us part two picks up Ellie
and Joel's story several years after the
events of the first game Ellie and Joel
have settled in Jackson Wyoming amongst
a thriving community of survivors with
the threats of the world kept outside
the town's walls Jackson has been able
to find relative peace and even
stability Ellie is now 19 lives in her
own and has been able to forge lasting
relationships within the community scale
of one to ten how would you rate our
kiss from last night however this piece
is short-lived Jackson and Ellie suffer
a violent and traumatizing event Ellie
sets off back into the treacherous
outside world in search of retribution
and justice
her journey will take her to new parts
of the country previously unexplored in
the last of us the story spans multiple
seasons and climates from the
snow-capped mountains of Jackson to the
Loess Pacific Northwest
each introduces a wide range of exterior
and interior environments for you to
navigate and explore rendered in
meticulous detail and unprecedented
scale with the latest iteration of the
Naughty Dog Engine our goal was to make
these environments not only beautiful
but feel as grounded and authentic to
the cities they're based on as possible
much of the story unfolds in what
remains of Seattle a massive former
quarantine zone it's locales are
incredibly diverse spanning a dense city
center with a skyline of towering
high-rises to the beautiful suburbs and
stormy water fronts that surrounded the
city exhibits drastic shifts in
architecture elevation and weather and
with part two we've introduced new
traversal mechanics that afford greater
exploration and ways to navigate threats
Ellie is not only able to climb and jump
over gaps but she can use ropes to scale
vertical terrain or swing over obstacles
allowing you to discover new areas
resources and side narratives
these more open environments also create
new strategic considerations in combat
whether it's to get the jump on enemies
or bypass them entirely the lastest part
2 features some of the largest
environments we've ever created
horseback riding will allow Ellie to
quickly cover some of these expansive
terrains some streets are so flooded
that a boat is required to navigate
however the world of the last of us is
as lush and inviting as it is deadly as
Elian covers the path to finding those
who have wronged her she must face the
many threats of this unknown city in the
wake of the pandemic in the fall of the
quarantine zone Seattle has become a war
zone where two warring factions find
themselves in an ongoing conflict for
territory and resources one of these
groups is the Washington Liberation
Front otherwise known as the W LF the W
are left for militia group that began as
resistance to the military occupation of
Seattle and eventually wrestled control
the city from them they are highly
trained organized and well equipped with
weapons they stole from the army they
occupy much of the city imprisoning or
killing trespassers on sight
on the other side of this bloody
conflict is a group of religious zealots
called Kucera fights or scars defined by
the self inflicted deep cuts that they
bear across their faces like the W left
are deeply tribalistic and territorial
they're known for being stealthy using
overgrowth as cover and they use more
silent weapons like bows and arrows clip
her wings
[Music]
but beyond this conflict among survivors
the threat that originally brought the
world to its knees is very much present
every human is in danger of falling
victim to the infected they are the
recently infected runners who are more
numerous and aggressive than escaped the
blind but extremely that the clickers
and the stalkers who sneak and hide
until they're ready to attack surprising
the victims of extreme agility and
brutal violence the Last of Us part 2
introduces new stages of infected such
as the shamblers large heavily armored
enemies that are covered in pustules
upon getting close to you they expel a
corrosive spore cloud the burns its
victims but our most terrifying and
lethal new forms of infected will have
to wait until you play the game for
yourselves
overcoming these threats will require
careful consideration of how you
approach every combat encounter and how
you leverage Ellie's unique skills
equipment and the environment to your
advantage something the WLF patrolled
the streets of Seattle with guard dogs
which are capable of detecting and
following you even while on cover you
think these guys they can pick up your
scent and alert their handlers to your
presence listen mode will reveal your
scent trail so keep moving and cause
distractions to avoid detection 25 years
after the pandemic began the world has
completely overgrown use tall grass to
hide from enemies and go prone to stay
out of sight however this form of
analogue stealth means you're never
fully hidden if enemies get close enough
they can discover you even ingress when
Ellie is overwhelmed running aways a
viable option you can also break glass
or crawl through tight spaces to find
new paths or areas to evade or take on
your enemies and any given combat
situation you can flee an encounter and
re-establish stealth to regain the
advantage if you absolutely have to
fight your way out there are a variety
of tools at your disposal Ellie's more
agile and most of her enemies she can
sprint and quickly dodge incoming
attacks learning how opponents attack
with different weapons and mastering the
timing of your dodges will prevent you
from taking damage and create
opportunities to counter-attack you can
use throw ball items or well-placed
shots to stun enemies before dealing a
killing blow
or using them as a shield to protect
yourself or buy some time to figure out
your next move
Ellie isn't always alone on her journey
allies will take part in helping you
navigate the environments spot enemies
and meaningfully help you in combat
encounters
[Music]
between the human survivors and the
roaming infected there will be times
where multiple threats are present
creating new strategic considerations
and opportunities you can choose whether
to attack these opponents separately and
directly or find ways to pit them
against each other
please they fight or wait until their
numbers have thinned out and engaged
with whoever's left
our goal is to create
unparallel attention coupled with deep
systems that give you greater control
and influence over your journey as you
play you'll be able to invest in a broad
collection of crafting items weapon and
player upgrades through training manual
scattered throughout the environment and
scavenging for ingredients these skills
and upgrade manuals cater to a variety
of play styles and the choices you make
will create your own distinct experience
we also wanted to extend that agency and
personalization to your weapons to our
new workbench systems scavenger parts to
modify and improve your weapons
performance and attributes all of which
are visualized and become part of your
character
[Music]
[Music]
survival will also require using the
parts and ingredients into a fine an
environment which can be crafted into a
wide range of defensive and offensive
items like proximity mines explosive
arrows pistol suppressors and more
[Music]
all of these gameplay systems are meant
to immerse you in the world and make you
feel and lockstep with Ellie's emotional
journey as we've said before this is
Naiya dogs largest the most ambitious
game it may seem like we covered a lot
but we've only scratched the surface of
what it's like to play The Last of Us
part two we can't wait for you to
experience it all for yourself on June
19th
[Music]
until then here's an extended sequence
of never-before-seen